we covered monitoring gk infrastructure
and services in the previous episode
but gke is not the only place you can
run containers in google cloud today
we'll look at three options for running
containers and how to instrument each
one for observability with cloud
operations welcome to engineering for
reliability with google cloud
let's start by reviewing your options
for running containers in google cloud
and how you might choose between them
your first option is of course gke or
google kubernetes engine it's a great
way to deploy scale and manage
kubernetes clusters in the cloud and use
them to orchestrate your container
workloads
gk is the industry's first fully managed
kubernetes service and it implements the
full kubernetes api 4-way auto-scaling
release channels and multi-cluster
support
your second option is cloud run either
as a fully managed serverless offering
or on gke clusters cloud run abstracts
away infrastructure management by
automatically scaling up and down from
zero and almost instantaneously by
responding to incoming traffic
and cloudrun only charges you for the
exact resources you use
your third option is anthos it's a
managed application platform that
extends google cloud services and
engineering practices to your
environment so you can modernize apps
faster and establish operational
consistency across them
with so many options how do you choose
gke is a fantastic option if you prefer
to manage and operate kubernetes
clusters directly or need that level of
control over your infrastructure
gke is also great because of its google
cloud marketplace integration which lets
you access enterprise ready
containerized solutions with pre-built
deployment templates portability
simplified licensing and consolidated
billing
cloud run is a great choice as a fully
serverless platform it makes app
development and deployment simple and
fast
and it's fully integrated with cloud
code cloud build cloud monitoring and
cloud logging for a complete end-to-end
developer experience
finally anthos is the right choice for
many enterprises where hybrid or
multi-cloud is a reality it lets you
extend the best of google cloud to your
environments no matter where they are so
you can modernize apps and establish
operational consistency across
infrastructure
now that you understand your options
let's have a look at how to instrument
your services running on them to send
telemetry to cloud operations for a
consistent approach to observability
let's start with gke we've covered much
of this in previous episodes but let's
have a look at how to get visibility
into both the infrastructure and your
services
let's start by inspecting our cluster
here we can confirm that we have both
system and workload logging enabled and
monitoring enabled for the cluster
this means that we'll get logs from our
containers and cluster infrastructure
and infrastructure metrics ingested
automatically let's head over to
monitoring and have a look
we'll start at the gke dashboard
here we can see information about our
clusters their nodes
and the workloads and services running
on them
even down to the pod and container level
we can select a specific workload to get
information about it
here we can see if it's generating any
alerts
metrics that show its health and
behavior
and the logs it's generating
in this case the workload is a
deployment
if we want to know what pods or
containers are running in this
deployment we can filter the entire
dashboard by that resource
we can then see the actual container
running in our workload and get its
metrics and even container logs
note that workloads on gke do not have
automatic tracing enabled
have a look at our previous episode on
distributed tracing with open telemetry
if this is something you need
gke is well integrated with cloud
operations and makes it easy to monitor
and observe both your infrastructure and
services
now let's have a look at managing
services on cloud run
from the project dashboard let's go to
the products menu and select cloud run
cloudron homepage shows all services
running in the project
when we select our service the metrics
tab will show some of the key
performance indicators like request
count broken have our response code
class and latency with 50th 95th and
99th percentile latency is automatically
calculated
so metrics that we would want to use as
service level indicators or slis are
created for us right out of the box
we can switch to the logs tab to see the
logs for our service and even view them
in the logs explorer
here we can analyze and query logs from
our cloud run service using queries the
field explorer or the histogram
you can review our previous episode on
cloud logging for more details if you
like
back on the metrics screen
we can also open cloud trace and go
directly to the list of traces for our
service
we can select the trace and see detailed
information for that request including
total latency and any dependencies our
service might have so this is how
container applications running on cloud
run are automatically instrumented to
send metrics logs and traces to cloud
operations
finally let's have a look at how antos
clusters are integrated with cloud
operations to provide visibility into
the infrastructure no matter where it's
running and your services
from the project dashboard let's go to
gke clusters
here we have two clusters running on gk
in the cloud
and another cluster managed by anthos
let's have a look at how we can start to
visualize the health of the cluster and
the workloads running on it
our first dashboard shows us the status
of the control plane
including the availability of the api
server scheduler and controller manager
we can also see the status of the
infrastructure
and understand how our nodes are using
cpu memory and disk resources
finally we can look at the status of the
actual workloads running in our anthos
cluster
by understanding metrics like container
cpu memory usage restarts and network
traffic
to understand more about what's
happening with our container workloads
we go to logging and look at logic
explorer
here we can look at kubernetes container
logs and filter them to just the logs
being emitted by services running in the
anthos managed cluster
we can scroll down and select a specific
pod or container we're actually
interested in
for example if we want to get the logs
being generated by our front end we can
select that as the pod name to filter
the logs to just those
so this is how cloud operations can help
you visualize metrics and analyze logs
being emitted by your container
workloads running on an antos cluster
thanks for joining me today we covered
your options for running containers in
google cloud and how to observe both the
infrastructure and your services for
each one i hope this helps you run more
reliable container services and keep
your users happy thanks so much for
watching don't forget to like and
subscribe to never miss out on more
engineering for reliability with google
cloud see you soon
you